grammy or or championship ring which one
i say championship easy
welcome to the first episode of chips i
am the host draymond green
our first guest five-time all-star
what's up dang what's good bro carrying
that chip on your shoulder what does
that mean to you
everything that i felt was up against me
um i've used it as basically wood on the
fire it's to the point now where i know
what it means to me to
have that chip that i find [ __ ] to hold
on to damian lillard is a guy who gets
motivated by a lot of different things
this guy will do whatever it takes to
win
where does that come from why do you
embody that
so much um i think it comes from my
upbringing
you know more than anything else when i
look back on
my childhood it was i was always second
to somebody
the first high school i went to arroyo
in san lorenzo
i transferred to st jones and alameda
and i ain't played my whole sophomore
year
and did you not play because they didn't
want you on the team or
was it because of you transfer or
transfer rule no i was i was eligible to
play
oh wait so you were on the team and just
didn't get no tick
yeah i was on the [ __ ] bro [ __ ] that's
crazy
coach was like man you think you're
gonna you can make it to the nba and i
was like yeah
he he chuckled and laughed in my face
bruh
wow he literally he literally like
smiled at me in my face and i was just
like
i'd never forget when he said that and
it was that summer when we played aau
we played against the t-mac we played
the t-mac all-stars
and i was just killing they like i
remember seeing lorenzo romar
roy williams i'm leaving the court i'm
like man i'm good
so we get to the hotel brother nothing
like nothing so i'm like damn like i
ain't getting nothing from that
i think from that moment it was like i
felt slighted
say i'm outspoken they be quiet my mouth
talking i've been out in the field
for real not a drill this ain't the
route chosen but my appeal fit with the
real fame without boasting less of a
thrill more navy's fuel
so you go to weber you have a great
four-year career
breaking all types of scoring records
you're then drafted
with the sixth pick the portland
trailblazers select
damien lillard of weaver state
university
to the world that's high yes
but something tells me that
you weren't really feeling that either
you know like the six pick wasn't high
enough for you
i was like man i should have went in my
head i was like
i could go number two in this draft me
being drafted at 35th pick though
i can name 15
small four power fours that went before
me that i knew right then like yo
this dude not better than me i go back
and look at our drive
and i say there's three people that'll
get drafted before me
if our draft was redone adu
and brad fast forward to today
where would you get drafted that today i
think i would be the second figure
millard
[Applause]
[Music]
more times than not everyone especially
you know in a situation where the number
one pig
plays he plays well which 80 did he
played he played well
but you beat him for a rookie of the
year
that was a personal challenge that i put
on myself
lillard for the win the
rookie of the month in november breaks
the hearts
of the hornets i want my first uh
western conference rookie of the month i
was like that's one down
and then the next month ricky out of
money again that's two of them
the next one rookie at the money game so
once we got there
it became a conversation i didn't
realize you won a rookie on a month that
many times which
bro and that goes to show that it was
actually still a conversation
i know people started saying like men
hate for sure again here you know damn
ricky of the year like even in our arena
they started saying
tonight you will see the very likely nba
rookie of the year
damian lillard i voted today and i voted
for him i'm not about to get
no reason to bring the conversation back
in any other direction it's like they're
gonna have to steal it they're gonna
have to rob me
overflow with success i wanna apologetic
scared money make nine tell
you often talk about respect you know in
your interviews
you often yelling it on the court you
know put some respect on my name i've
seen you yell before
at times i personally felt like steve
curt
didn't necessarily have the most
confidence in me didn't have
the trust in me that i know my play
warranted i know that i've proven you
know and so
there was a lot of times for me on the
court while i hit a three and i look
over at him you know i'm saying like
yeah you like i can shoot who do you be
feeling
you need to get that respect from is it
players is it fans
is it the media it's interesting you
said that about steve kirkus i felt that
way
a few years of my career i'm looking at
steph and russ
and cp and i don't view them as above me
the way i see people speak on my name
sometimes you know it's almost like
he's a great player but you know he like
but what
it's lillard he got the shut off
and the blazers win the series
[Applause]
you always speaking of this championship
drive and yet you know your loyalty have
stayed with portland
it's bringing that championship to
portland important to you or is getting
a championship
importing you it's important for me to
win a championship here
you know i think if you go and play for
some of these teams like they've won it
in the recent
recent time they want it you know i'm
saying so it would be special because
you went in the championship but it
wouldn't
it wouldn't mean the same to that that
fan base that's it
everybody don't get to be a multi-time
champion
everybody don't get to be a champion
everybody don't get there fast some
people get there like look at dirk
you know what i'm saying like that's the
person i look at and i'm like it'll be
worth it
if we can build a team here after i i
didn't already went through all the
horror [ __ ]
yeah and like why not be here and they
ain't won it since 77
so what would that mean that's a special
thing though and i can relate
the warriors hadn't won one since i
think 75
when we when we won that chess so that's
77 like that's a special thing
if i can have one like that
i'm coming back on your show bruh
okay